cnn  still  doesn't have a description of the  suspect they did not at as of 9 00 30 10  30 eastern sorry a.m on monday  so either they're not doing their job  they're really bad at their job or  they're lying at what point do they  cease to be useful at what point do we  realize that they are not news  organizations 20 years ago yeah you  would think so yeah uh uh one of the  last time ted turner wrote out in a  steer um  here's the police scanner that reported  the suspect  this happened you would think they'd  have access to it considering that we  did well with that jerrell brooks said  rings for anything  moving april i ran that subject my  friend's id in the car he is suspended  looks like he's actually at least 199 on  the system  that's what he's identifying  lighter skin black male dreadlocks  rapture polluted no shoes  now i guess what cena would have  preferred the description be uh